i ragazzi stavo pensando una cosa visto
che siamo qui tutti insieme riuniti no
perché non facciamo l'albero di natale
si fa però scusate un attimo ragazzo ma
che giorno è oggi 18 novembre ma perché
no vuol dire che nessuno di quelli vuole
fare l'albero è dato preciso a roma
antica celadon fai quando voi ce l'avete
lo spirito laveri quando arriva certo è
arrivato pancia ragazzi ma visto che
siamo tutti insieme no riuniti perché
non facciamo un albero di natale ma
scusami male ma che giorno è oggi dai 13
no ragazzi come da tradizione l'albero
si fa all 8 dicembre
ragazzi siamo a milano ea milano
l'albero si fa 7 giorno saltano e magari
ma il suo albero stiamo a casa sua in
tavola come siamo tutti insieme mi
sembra aver barato il dai e rompiamo st
tradizione secolare va bene io mi
rifiuto
[Musica]
dai ragazzi animo suo bello fare
l'albero ripassiamo un attimo e vuole
allora giorgi tu sarai l'ha detta
l'apertura dei rami mi raccomando eh
tutti questi buchi non ci devono essere
belli aperti per i pomposi tu invece ti
occuperai delle lucine è che di pale e
bellissimo mettere le luci all'albero di
natale dai e invece i do che ha un
bellissimo senso artistico si occuperà
delle palline quindi i ruoli sono
definiti tutto chiaro possiamo iniziare
a busa tu cosa fai
e io mi occupo della playlist musicale
volete avere un bel sottofondo musicale
di the fate l'albero ci pensa marina ci
vediamo dopo ragazzi ciao ballero
allora ragazzi ripassiamo velocemente
anche se so che siete già molto
preparati prima le luci e poi le
parallele ma mi raccomando sotto quelle
più grandi
e su quel piccolo esatto iniziamo subito
ma cosa stai facendo marina cos'è sta
roba
siete andati via e mi sono portato
avanti ha iniziato a mettere le quali
manager 86 andati a prenderli
uccideranno prima queste ma chi ha detto
ma se io non so se io non puoi prima le
palline come fare no ma guai a ma poi
quest ma perché liste mettendoli ma no
ma prima vanno quelle grosse in basso e
poi alla fine in alto ci sono assenti
dai metalli e micro non più tanto agli
questo dai tagli
i ragazzi comunque per questo natale
avevo pensato una cosa super carina da
fare praticamente dopo aver messo tutte
le palline ognuno di noi scrive dei
biglietti dei tre biglietti vi scriviamo
dei nostri desideri e poi quando avremo
i regali tutti insieme leggeremo i
bigliettini cercando di capire a chi
appartiene il desiderio di riina ma
cos'è sta roba allora perché non appende
i biscotti di pan di zenzero e l'arci la
tazza per babbo natale marina cresce un
po
[Musica]
sta venendo perfetto allora ragazzi mi
raccomando riempiamolo tutto non
lasciano spazi il dietro indietro deve
essere come il cav anti non facciamo
differenze ladro deve essere equilibrato
e perfetto su ogni lato
bravissimi a proposito intravede un
piccolo spazio dietro richiamo subito
ragazzi stavo pensando una cosa se non
mettiamo palline dietro non si offende
nessuno ci concentriamo qui mettiamo
tutte le pagine più belle qui quello un
po meno carina ai lati dietro moto
perfetta di qua va bene sono stati
veramente le vacanze e gli ata ii più
belle della mia vita ma domenica scemi
domenica fa in pratica siamo veramente
divertiti
anzi mi dispiace proprio separarmi da
voi no adesso che ci penso
se facessi una bella cioccolata calda e
mi aiutate a smontare l'albero stiamo
ancora un po insieme no comunque sono
state delle vacanze i natali bellissime
no si beh più o meno è stata sempre al
telefono capito ma io non so sciare
la regina del bob e poi tu dormi di
sempre io mi di anche restituire il mio
maggiore ovvero comunque stavo pensando
si faccia una bella cioccolata calda e
mi aiutate a smontare dai ragazzi ma chi
lo dirà mai fa in pratica più in fretta
[Musica]